hopefully
we squish out a nugget
one the end of 2021 we we start trying
okay maybe
it's up to you babe it's been two years
since that convo played out between
Justin and Haley Bieber and now Haley's
explaining why they didn't stick to that
timeline admitting she has some
reservations about having little ones
with her hubby he's just really sweet
he's a good kid he's a good part and uh
I love him the model tells the Sunday
Times that while she wants kids so bad
she's scared of the scrutiny they could
face for having famous parents something
she knows about firsthand her dad is
Actor Stephen Baldwin my children are
probably getting a little bit different
counseling and guidance quote it's
enough that people say things about my
husband or my friends I can't imagine
having to confront people saying things
about a child you betcha you betcha yeah
and we've all witnessed Haley's struggle
in the spotlight especially when it
comes to online hate in the wake of the
drama with Selena Gomez who dated Justin
before Haley on social media it can
really tear people down not neither
woman's outright come for the other but
fans have pitted them against each other
for years despite their requests to make
it stop I think some
of the things that I don't even need to
be aware of are just vile and disgusting
and this year it came to a head Haley
describing the start of 2023 as some of
the saddest hardest moments she's ever
had in her adult life now she tells the
times she's accepted that there's no
winning ever when it comes to the
internet's perception of her I have a
life and I have a career and I have my
own friends so trying to balance making
my
wants and needs and hopes and dreams
work while meshing my life with another
human who has his hopes and dreams and
career and like we're busy people and we
want to be in a marriage so we're making
it work and the beepers are looking
forward to their future together which
will definitely involve babies at some
point
last year source told E.T Haley and
Justin believe a big family is in their
Destiny both know what great parents
they are going to be together they both
feel like part of their reason for being
on Earth was to be parents it's an
amazing feeling Haley gave the times a
new timeline she's hoping they'll be
parents in the next five years I say
that now and then I bet you when I have
kids I'm gonna be like I didn't even
know what patience was before that quote
there's only one time that we're going
to get to do this so it's about trying
my best to soak it up and enjoy it and
love my people and what I do that's what
is really important to me I'm excited
and as far as how they'll handle Haley's
fears she says she and Justin can only
do the best they can to raise them as
long as they feel loved and safe
[Music]
foreign